[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci infiniment c'est un prix qui nous
touche énormément comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer dans le film de personnages
partage ce constat il y a quelque chose
qui cloche entre les femmes et les
hommes
c'est un euphémisme
le
morbide des contes de la violence faite
aux femmes tient en une phrase
un décès tous les trois jours et dans
les mauvaises années tous les deux jours
seuls les femmes savent dans leur chair
ce qu'est la violence qu'on leur inflige
mais pourtant qu'en Dominique et Gilles
sont venus nous voir avec l'envie de
faire ce film il nous est apparu évident
qu'il y avait un manque que le regard
des hommes étaient importants qu'il
fallait donner la parole à ces hommes là
et que les cinéastes devaient absolument
s'emparer de ce récit
Dominique il y a quelques jours tu as
donné un interview et tu as cité la
philosophe Geneviève Fraisse qui a dit
quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup frappé
c'est que Mitou a libéré la parole mais
qu'il s'agissait maintenant de libérer
l'écoute
or dans le film de Dominique les hommes
écoutent ils écoutent d'autres hommes
débités un flot de
proposé sans se rendre compte de rien
mais surtout ils écoutent des femmes et
des femmes qui leur tendent un miroir
sans concession et je pense que si le
film nous bouleverse c'est pour cela
mais c'est aussi pour cela qu'il nous
apaise profondément et que nous en
avions tous et toutes très profondément
besoin donc je dirais vive les femmes et
vivent les hommes qui rejoignent leur
combat parce que ce combat nous devons
le mener ensemble merci
merci à vous tous merci infiniment
merci à nos partenaires qui nous suivent
depuis plus de enfin près de 30 ans dans
nos prises de risques
et surtout merci aux artistes qui par
leurs œuvres éclairent nos jours et nos
nuits et j'ai une pensée ce soir plus
particulière pour ces mêmes artistes qui
loin d'ici ou pas si loin d'ailleurs
meurt sous des bombes meurent dans des
prisons pour avoir voulu porter leur
voix donc je pense à eux ce soir et je
pense à nous en France qui avant de la
chance de vivre dans un pays où il y a
encore des médias libres et indépendants
où il y a encore des lieux pour montrer
les oeuvres pour montrer de la diversité
du monde et cet équilibre en fait il est
fragile donc j'ai envie de dire
protégeons le vive le cinéma
merci beaucoup
alors je voulais parce que j'ai pas
réussi à le caser tout à l'heure mais ça
va paraître un peu anecdotique mais en
fait je voudrais remercier les
enquêteurs de la PJ de Grenoble qui
m'ont accueilli pendant une semaine
et ce stage d'immersion a été très
important pour la justesse du film voilà
donc je voulais les remercier pour leur
confiance et ensuite je
voulais avoir une pensée pour la vraie
classe c'est-à-dire la vraie victime de
l'affaire qui voilà qui a donné lieu à
au film voilà elle s'appelait Maud merci
[Applaudissements]